- On this episode, we talk to
three crazy Snapchatters
and learn all
about their lives.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 196
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
As you can see we continue the
theme though we did throw in 195
that was finally
me by myself here.
Is that airing today?
- [Staphon] That's 194.
- That's all
fucking confusing, DRock.
Just traveling with
me everywhere.
Anyway, we continuing the theme
of having guests on which I am
enjoying quite a bit and similar
to the influencer show where we
talked about
YouTube and Snapchat
and things of that nature.
On this episode, we have
three phenomenally talented
individuals that have different
skill sets from being amazing at
sweating to drawing.
We'll allow them all a
few seconds now to explain
themselves but this is a very
hard core focus on something
we've been talking about for a
couple of years but intensely
for the last 6 months and really
intensely for the last three
months which is Snapchat.
All these three lovely, massively
attractive individuals are all
very influential and deep into
their Snapchat universe so kids
why don't you introduce
yourself to the Vayner Nation.
Tell them who you are and a
little bit about yourself.
Let's keep these to 30, 40
seconds and then we'll expand on
these things but I want your
name but you kind of do and then
how you kind of stumbled in
into the Snapchat Universe.
Let start with the lady.
- Okay.
I can do that in 10 seconds.
- Respect.
- Hi my name is Cyrene Q.
I go on Snapchat as Cyrene Q
but my name is Cyrene Quiamco.
I do Snapchat art.
I draw on Snapchat and tell
stories and I use art as kind of
an on-the-go special effects.
- How did your
Snapchat journey start?
- It started off actually
with The 11th Second.
I was an admirer of other
people's art and I created a
website and it became a
discovery site and then I grew--
- What did you
build it on top of?
Was it a Tumblr or an Instagram?
- It wasn't a Tumblr.
It was a blogger and after that
it migrated into a WordPress.
- Got it.
- It's a big site right now.
Basically, that's how I started
and then the community grew and
then we started
helping each other grow.
- That's amazing.
Very nice.
And you're from where?
- I'm from Arkansas,
Little Rock, Arkansas.
- Love that. Alright, my man.
- My name is Mike Platco
go by mplatco on Snapchat.
Like Cyrene, artist, storyteller
I downloaded Snapchat just like
everybody else did because
people were talking about it.
Started making these
insanely intricate drawings
of myself as Harry Potter.
Had a bunch of them.
Put them on Tumblr, went
viral started getting calls from
brands so that is
my full-time career.
- That's amazing
and where are you from?
- Boston.
Are you a Patriots fan?
- No. I'm an Eagles fan.
- Great. That was huge.
That made me be very happy.
My man. You're sweating
because you ran to get here.
- I already missed my
meeting with this guy.
- Huge mistake.
- Yeah.
- Billion dollar mistake.
My name is Taylor Nikolai,
Taylor.Nikolai on Snapchat.
- The dot for emphasis?
- There was a girl took
TaylorNikolai before I could and
I offered to buy from her and
she blocked me on Snapchat.
- How much did you offer?
- I offered $500.
- That's a solid number.
- This is like a year ago.
- Solid number.
- Anyway I'm Taylor.Nikolai.
You pronounce my name Nikolai
and the song is N-I-K-O-L-A-I,
that's how you spell Nikolai.
I'm really awkward and that's
why people like me I guess.
- I love it. You can sing.
- [Cyrene] Can you sing my name?
- Yeah, sing my name too.
Try to spell
Vaynerchuk right now.
- V-A-Y-N-E-R-C-H-U-K.
- Oh he got it.
No C.
- I know how to
spell Vaynerchuk.
- Cool, get that clip.
I want that to be my ring.
Alright, so look--
- I'm from Minnesota
and I'm a Vikings fan.
- I love that.
I know the owners of
the Vikings quite well.
They're from Springfield,
New Jersey where
Wine Library is from.
Where my career started.
- Do you want to
give me some tickets?
- Sure. Do you want
them to be good?
- Yes.
- Okay, done.
So gang, I think we're going
to answer some questions.
India, you're here too.
- [India] I am.
- And you also draw on Snapchat.
- [India] I do.
- You do?
- Yeah.
Someone doesn't
watch my stories.
- I really don't watch
anybody's stories.
I really don't,
I'm the worst.
Will you now up
your drawing game?
Have you been motivated by the
first 40 seconds of the show?
- Yes, already.
- Oh Nick. Show this.
This is amazing, DRock.
Please show
what's happening here.
Nick, why don't you tell her who
you are which makes what you're
doing right now way
more fun for everybody.
- Hey everybody.
I'm Nick Cicero CEO and
founder of Delmondo and we work
with Snapchat influencers and
we have Snapchat analytics.
So we brought these
three guys to the show.
And I'm doing the microphone.
- Yes, he is.
All right, India,
let's get into this show.
- [India] Three video questions.
- Okay.
- [India] They're going to ask
you a question--
- Great. Let's do it.
- [India] and then
you're going to talk--
- Awesome.
- [India] and this
one is from Matteo.
- Matteo.
- [India] Are you guys good?
- [DRock] No. Stopped.
- [India] Should I wait?
- [DRock] Yeah.
But doesn't my
mic pick stuff up?
So the sound will be
not as good for a second.
- [Staphon] While
this is for the video.
- Do you have wine
because you like wine?
- Me? So up there you'll see I
grew up in the wine business.
- Yeah, I'm joking.
These are jokes.
- Got it. Following along.
I don't like assuming
people know stuff.
I think it's a douchey move.
Who's that?
- That's my friend.
- I figured.
- [Cyrene] Is it okay if I post
from CEO to mic holder?
- Yes! That's exactly what
you should be posting.
- [Nick] This is fair game.
- So I actually have 7
million twitter followers.
- That's amazing.
- Friends with Jerome.
- Yes.
- I was the guy who first posted
his Vines on the Internet.
- That's amazing.
That's really cool.
You have it under
your account across
a bunch of different sites?
- I have 33
different twitter accounts.
I run @FunnyVines
on Twitter,
like all the big
twitter accounts.
- [Taylor and Gary] The show.
(all laughing)
- [Nick] You should just do
one long one of those all day.
- Can we go? I have
a client meeting.
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- We're good?
All right, India,
let's get into this?
- Hey Gary.
I'm Matteo from Italy.
Amazing country.
Super girls, super food but dire
strait of gambling addiction.
I opened a non-profit that
operates in the space
and I would like to hear
from you on this point.
As a marketer, how to involve
our members to spread the
no gambling cause so to
reach more and more people.
Thanks a lot. You rock.
- The no gambling cause.
Italy has great food and great
women but a gambling problem.
- And so how do we?
- How do you advance
the no gambling cause?
- Matteo wants me to help him
do a marketing campaign
to stop people from gambling?
- [India] Basically.
- Because he thinks
gambling is ruining Italy.
- [India] Yes.
- The food and the
girls part is fine but
the gambling is a problem?
- [India] Yes.
- And so he wants to create
a marketing campaign
to stop gambling?
- [India He just wants to
know your thoughts would
be to advance the
no gambling cause.
Any cause regardless of what,
by the way I like gambling.
Any cause's expansion
has to do the right creative
in the right medium.
To me, if he's got a lot of
passion to stop the gambling
cause there's a very smart
strategy tying in what we're
doing here to go younger.
Usually the thing that you need
to do to stop the movement is to
go younger, it's really no
different than Facebook and
Snapchat even, the
generational differences.
The way you get people to
stop using drugs or drinking and
driving and all the things that
have happened in propaganda in
the US to stop things that
people were concerned about was
you've got to win the youth
culture around that subject
matter and then let it mature.
So I think Matteo and the people
in Italy that want to stop the
gambling culture in that
country should be looking more
aggressively toward
Snapchat and Instagram.
Two platforms that are
doing extremely well
in their country.
Anything to add youngsters, I
know that's kind of a left-field
question, I'm not sure
where India was
going with that strategy.
- [India] Well,
Andy just pinged me.
That question wasn't
supposed to be there, sorry.
- See, that made sense to me.
Thanks for ruining the show.
Let's go to next question.
- Can't go to Vegas.
- What's up Gary?
My name is Aaron Martinez and
I hope you like the hat but my
question for you is I have a
YouTube channel that has grown
from 0 to 88,000 subscribers in
a little bit under 10 months.
Now on my channel I upload
Snapchat tips and tricks but
I try to do a little bit of other
things in the earlier stages of
my channel but they
didn't really work out.
Going into the future may be
passing 100,000 subscribers,
what do you think I should do?
Primarily stick to Snapchat or
try to do different things
and if so what?
Thanks guys over VaynerMedia.
I hope you guys have a nice day.
- Aaron I think and I'll let
these guys jump in because I'm
sure they have a lot to add to
this unlike the first question.
Aaron, I think a couple
things that struck me with that
question, number one, this
magical number of 100,000
followers or your first thousand
or a million, I'm telling you
and I'm telling this because
of a lot of heart for the
youngsters sitting with me right
now these are the wrong metrics
to reverse engineer against.
More importantly if you were
here what I would need to know
we were just talking for second
as DRock broke the sound
is what do you want to happen.
I think one of the biggest
mistakes by so many Snapchat and
YouTube influencers right now
they want to become Hollywood
famous because they grew up
where that was the pinnacle and
to me I keep trying to remind
them my early days with Jerome
and Rudy and Brittany Furlan and
that whole space with the Vine
influencers that were definitely
the spark that you've watched
have the Instagram and Snapchat
thing very different than the
generation of YouTube
that I grew up with.
In 2022, in 2024 the most
famous person is not the person
that's on a TV show on MTV, it's
a person that's dominates this
which is the new television.
Just like being a cable star
wasn't interesting in the early
80s but then eventually if
you're the number one star on
HBO show which to remind
everybody, you guys are too
young for this, HBO's was shit.
HBO was a shit place
to go 1982, 1984, 1986.
You were a B,
C-list, D-list, F-list.
Nobody wanted to be a
Netflix star 48 months ago.
Nobody.
Now everybody
wants to in Hollywood.
First and foremost, Aaron, I
think that you need to decide
what you want to happen.
You want to get your
art into the world?
Is it about money?
Is it about fame?
And I think you need to own
your vanity 'cause way too many
people try to
bullshit it, number one.
Number two, you gotta go
where the attention is.
To me, enormous emphasis on
Snapchat and YouTube and now
look one minute Instagram videos
probably opens up a lot of
creativity for a lot of people
here and definitely people that
are watching so that
because a new thing.
Look, MusicAlly, actually
this is a question from me real
quick, are any of the three
of you playing on MusicAlly?
- Yeah, I downloaded it
after hearing you talk
about it a couple of times.
- Have you had the time yet to
look at what's going on there?
- Little bit.
- This is what so
interesting, right.
A lot of my YouTube
celebrity friends when
Vine came along were like eh.
I'm like you came from
YouTube that's what was just
being said five minutes ago.
Then a lot when Snapchat came
I was telling a lot of Viners,
like this thing I'm telling
you and they're like eh.
And then of course now
everybody's there and
now even MusicAlly right?
Snapchat its at it's apex but
ironically I think Snapchatters
as I'm giving you advice right
that go and really go all in on
on MusicAlly are going to win
those junior high people are
gonna be here in 36 months
and be like holy shit that was
such a good idea
or it could go away.
But much like what happened
on Vine, this is such a good
learning from Vine, we were
talking about Vine off
as DRock broke the sound.
The people that won on Vine
have been able to siphon that
attention and be
successful on other platforms.
Not everybody.
- Some.
- Exactly.
Not everybody because some of
them would held on Vine either
because it didn't have enough
talent to be anything more than
a few minutes but some were.
And it's no different than being
a really good actor on a hit
show on CBS for two seasons and
then coming back two years later
on ABC and siphoning
some of that audience and
building on that momentum.
These are channels and
doing the right thing.
Aaron, I think what you need to
use this and I would say this
the three individuals here
who I have a lot of heart for.
80% tripling down on what works.
You guys can fucking draw.
You're funny and intriguing.
All that stuff.
- Can't draw.
- I cannot draw as well.
- But you want to learn?
- Maybe someday.
- Never?
- Never.
- Correct.
So 80% of that and
20% experimenting.
That's what you should be doing,
Aaron, from my point of view.
Gang?
- Can I say something?
- Yes.
- Nobody cares
about subscribers?
Nobody cares about followers?
It's all about influence.
If you can actually create a
sustainable amount of influence
or something that you can
actually push to other platforms
that's something
people care about.
Numbers is not something that
people are going to care about
in the future.
100,000 subscribers or a
million subscribers if nobody is
consistently watching
your videos nobody cares.
- I agree with that.
Brands care now
'cause they're not
sophisticated in
their language.
- They won't three
years from now though.
- Well it depends.
The answer is results should
and always do matter at the end.
There's a lot of things.
A metric can be accepted by a
marketplace like Nielsen ratings
that doesn't map to a results
yet the entire $80 billion
advertising industry most
of it doesn't quantify
against actual results.
They quantify against metrics.
I'm with you.
And by the way all my
behavior maps to your rant.
- Right.
- That's what I'm living.
No question--
- Metrics in general are broken.
The whole industry
is broken on metrics.
- The metric that should
matter is how many did you sell?
Of whatever that is.
And when I mean sell, you
know, I want you to
donate to my nonprofit.
That's a result or you did a
show and how many people showed
up to it to watch you
paint for an hour. India?
I think that's the case.
Any thoughts on
Aaron's questions?
It's funny we all
actually know Aaron--
- And you hate him.
- No, he's great.
- He's like the nicest guy.
- He does like Snapchat
tutorials and tips and
tricks on his YouTube.
Absolutely that's something we
need to us expand upon because
he has identify what he wants
to be not someon with 100,000
subscribers on YouTube.
Whatever he wants to
turn his career into and
then play to that.
I think you've clearly got some
chops and I think the question
becomes what, what do you that
at this young, and by the
way for all three of you, what
do you at this young of an age
want to happen and then try to
do project who you think you are
in the balance of vanity, money,
happiness, work-life balance,
these are a lot of things you
have to project at a young age.
Yeah, right.
And by the way everybody's got
different percentages of it.
Two minutes and that's that.
Let's move.
I've got this client thing.
We broke sound, we were late,
fucking people people running.
- [India] Ben.
- Ben.
- Yo Gary. What's up?
I'm Ben from Israel.
I'm a professional
Snapchat artist and YouTuber.
I have one very important
question to ask you in a country
that is known as a startup
nation there is one problem,
one ironic problem.
As much as were innovative
the problem is we suck
in social media marketing.
Now people here
just don't get it.
What we do the creators on
social media such as Snapchat
and YouTube are you
doing the correct thing.
They don't give us a
lot of room to work.
They don't pay us
to get our job done.
The thing is people like us want
to live doing so that we love.
And we know how to talk
to the right audience.
Now how can we convince the
mainstream media that what we do
is the right thing?
How can we convince someone so
big as the mainstream media to
change their ways and give
us, the underdog, the chance to
create something amazing to do
something that really counts?
Thanks man, appreciate
it and love your work.
- What is his name?
- [India] Ben.
- Ben.
What you have for Ben?
Well like what you said
everything's converting,
this is the new TV.
And so if the mainstream media
is still thinking about the
old-style they're going to miss
out on the new audience that's
becoming of this and I
think that there's not much
convincing, they can
just look at numbers.
They can look all the people
that are on Snapchat right now.
Less people are watching TV.
I'm not watching TV anymore.
If you ask all the other
people they're on YouTube,
they're on Snapchat and
it's becoming outdated.
- Absolutely go where to where
the audiences are and if you
have something
compelling to say, say it.
Make that content.
It doesn't matter if--
- But how do we answer his
question how do you think,
agreed we're all gonna head nod,
what about convincing these
individuals to do it?
You're in a tough spot right now
because it's coming to
you right now, right?
- Yeah.
- When the inbound traffic's
coming to you and saying
hey can you draw this for my
brand, you're not worried about
convincing 'cause
you don't have to.
Thoughts?
- First off, who cares what the
mainstream media thinks just do
what you're going to do anyway
and be consistent about it and
then success will eventually
come if you're talented.
Outside of that how do you get
what you deserve to be paid?
Well you're going to get what
you deserve to be paid and if
you're not getting what you
deserve to be paid then ask for
what you deserve to be paid.
- Or, I agree, very honestly.
That was a great
question but tough shit.
My whole life has been
predicated on selling something
that is ahead of the market.
You have to wait.
The answer is the market's
going to pay for what
they think it's worth.
People like us here couple
things I'm going to pick at
and I love you. Thank you
for the kind words.
People like us want to get paid
for something we want to create.
So does everybody.
Everybody wants to be able to
be paid to do what they love.
Every single athlete that grows
up from 6 to 14 years old would
like to be paid to be a
professional athlete.
Another thing that I liked and
I've heard this from this sector
including you guys,
I'm a professional
YouTube and Snapchat.
What does that mean?
Do you just say
we're professionals?
It sounds like if you're going
to say the word professional--
- I even hate the
word influencer.
I hate the word influencer.
- These get into semantics.
I've talked a lot
about this on the show.
You call whatever you want but
to me being a professional means
that you actually
do it for a living.
And so too many people
I'm that without being able
to do for a living.
This is what your
platform is trying to solve.
Here's what I would say,
you know, tough shit.
You live in Israel,
tough shit.
They're not spending
as much money.
The other thing is
you've got to prove it.
One thing that a lot of
influencers are not proving is
yeah you're talking
to the right audience.
Listen if you're
selling insurance the 40 to
60-year-olds, do you have the
audacity to tell them that they
should be on Snapchat to sell?
What you're going to say if you
really get put into the corner
is no, I don't know.
It's so funny.
I love watching everybody's,
everybody under 27 is.
And so if you're selling to
27 and unders in the US then
Snapchat and Instagram
becomes very compelling.
If you're selling retirement
home space, Snapchat's probably
not the right platform today.
I do think Snapchat, much like
Facebook, will age up in a way
that most people don't believe.
I do believe that in 24 months
most 55-year-old men
are on Snapchat.
And I think that
confuses people.
- Sooner than that.
- We'll see.
It's on the record
we're about to find out.
What happens is it that it
either happens or doesn't and
here's the more interesting part
whether or not it happens at all,
sooner than two years in
two years, is kind of irrelevant
because whatever does happen
is what you have to act around.
I would tell you that there's
plenty of people making money
off of Snapchat and YouTube,
you have to go and grab it to
your point and more importantly
if you don't then maybe you're
not a good salesperson and
maybe you're just a creative and
you actually need a sales partner.
There's that part of it.
Because the creative world
and the business world
are very often at odds.
There are a few that cross and
have both skills and mom and dad
had sex of the right moment
and gave them those talents
but a lot of people don't.
And that's something else
that we have to factor in.
India. That's it for those two.
- [India] That's just those two.
- Got it.
Alright, well do you
guys have any questions?
- Yeah, actually.
Obviously you're someone who has
intimate knowledge of how Vine
stars came to be and know which
ones took the right steps and
didn't so much.
Someone like Cyrene, like
myself, storytelling, drawing on
Snapchat a platform it's
vertical, where do you think a
logical next step would be if we
want to continue making content
like we're making knowing the
Snapchat can't just be the only
thing that we're on.
I think there's several
different things in play here.
Number one, first and foremost,
I really recommend to you and
this genre I would love for you
guys to make the physical
manifestation of
these products at scale.
I think one of the great
opportunities for you guys this
is not answering your question
I just want to get this in the
show before I forget.
I truly believe that both of
you have the ability to make
millions of dollars a year in
prints of your drawings
if you figure out that
connection point.
And you need to
think about that.
That is a real-life thing that
you need to figure out tomorrow.
- [Taylor] She's
already selling her's.
- I'm sure you are.
I think you have the ability to
take a snap that you draw on top
of and have 41,000 people
buy that $19 poster at scale.
I think that's a real business
for the artist the Snapchat.
That's random.
As far as your question, which
is if Snapchat was to have a 24
month more run because something
came along, I think you have to
understand, I know, I think you
have to understand that
your art is your skill set.
It's funny on Snapchat
right now that's
peaking very
aggressively.
For Taylor, his skill
translates to every medium.
Your advantage because
there's drawing capabilities
on top is different.
It is unique to that platform.
And that is something
have to think about.
And you have to think about
what does that actually mean.
And I would say that yours
doesn't naturally transpose into
everywhere else
because it stands out.
I still can't wrap around my
head around that picture that
you drew. So crazy but I don't
think if you drew it on a piece
of paper or if that was on a
post on Tumblr that I would
react the same way.
That's just truth and that's the
reality and guess what
that's just life.
The people that were amazing at
radio because they had amazing
voices and they were comfortable
to be in the booth and then went
to television and they were
scared of the camera, they lost.
And so that's something to
think about, that's just real.
Doesn't necessarily transpose.
Listen, you guys heard the
knocks, unfortunately he was
late and he broke sound and so
you we're going to have to
wrap up the show.
I apologize guys
but I have to go.
Actually, you know what,
let's do something interesting.
Why don't you guys talk for five
minutes and wrap up the show.
India, DRock do your thing.
I'm out they're going to
finish and we'll see you soon.
Love you guys.
First time it's rare.
Do your thing.
Figure it out.
- Everybody who's watching who's
in the Vayner Nation and still
thinks Snapchat is a terrible
investment of their time,
what would you say to them?
A very easy, very
simple question.
- You can't there's something
that there is so many people
using it's not a waste of time.
It's a beautiful app that is
just as conducive to absorbing
content as creating content.
My big mission is to get people
to go out and make things and
Snapchat is the
perfect segue into that.
For that reason alone you
should go out and learn
about making things.
It's incredibly
satisfying for me.
Download Snapchat and get on
it and start doing cool stuff.
- Why would it be
a waste of time?
There's like billions
of followers on it.
That's a platform that has
influencers has creators and
that can put a message out in
24 hours to thousands of people.
I don't think
that's a waste of time.
- There's certainly no other
platform that commands your
attention like Snapchat does.
- Yes.
- If you're in marketing or
social media and you're still
not sure about Snapchat, you're
stupid and you should quit your
job and never work in marketing
or social media ever again.
- Done.
- The fact you've even asked
that question signifies that
you're in the wrong industry.
So you were just, you weren't
actually asking that question.
I just want to be clear.
Devil's advocate, okay.
- We should talk about
like discovery on Snapchat.
Maybe Snapchat
will listen to us.
User discovery.
- Cyrene if I can ask you a
question, how did you start to
grow on Snapchat?
There's no discovery platform.
- There is no discovery platform
basically you have to take your
audience outside of Snapchat.
I basically screenshoted
your Snapchat, put you on the
website, you became friends with
me and you shouted me out,
I shouted you out.
I became friends of the people
and it's basically creating this
community that help each other
grow but we need something to
grow more than that community.
People are creating,
you create awesome content,
Taylor create awesome jokes like
never mind don't follow him.
- I wouldn't.
- They're so much and Snapchat
has this discovery channel with
awesome content but they're not
supporting this raw content that
creators from
everywhere are creating.
If they want to be this new
social media platform that has
the news, the content,
they have to start
supporting the creators.
And not just the paid brands,
the repurposed content
from other websites.
- Can I play devil's advocate?
- Yeah.
- Like I've told you I
don't want a discovery option.
I think that it would lead to
too quick of saturation and what
happens so often when there is
a discovery option like what we
saw on Vine is that the little
pretty teenage boys just so
often skyrocket to the top.
- I think you're
pretty teenage boy.
- I'm not a teenage boy.
- You don't want to grow?
- I think oversaturation is
such an easy thing to happen.
- It's not oversaturation
because on Netflix you have
thousands of stuff but
you only have a few ones.
People are going to
be more selective.
- If it's an editorial
discovery that's different
than a popular page.
I would say an editorial
discover page would be
something that
I would support.
But anything that's popular on
Snapchat is super gross to me.
- I think it be interesting to
see what would happen given that
the platform is so established
right now introducing it this
late in the game. It would
really be a game changer.
Vine it started out with that.
- Sorry, Gary forgot his phone.
Do you mind if I grab that?
Thank you so much.
- We should have stolen it
and like went on his Snapchat.
- Vine took a while
to get a popular page.
Didn't it?
- [Nick] Just this year.
- [India] On the rise now, too.
- I mean the ability to the
search-ability and sharing and
having any sort of
metrics tied to your content.
- Like loops just came.
One question I have for you guys
is when do you think Snapchat
will show views to public?
So we know how many views we get
but when do you think Snapchat
will show the public how
many views we have?
- I think keeping the public
the views private is
actually like less social.
For people who are not
influencing, they don't want to
show their views to the public.
- So do you not think that
they'll show views to public?
- I don't think they should
because there's billions of
people following and maybe like
100 influencers and we want to
show our views to the public but
other people don't want to show
they don't want to show
that I have 17 views or
17 of their friends do it.
- I know Snapchat influencers
with like 17 people watching.
That's a problem.
- You have to think like how
other people using it too.
There's the influencer part
and then there's the other part.
What do you do the other
billion people that doesn't
want to show their views?
And doesn't want to
be like Facebook.
Because it's like Snapchat is
popular because you can't see
the likes, you can't see
the views and people can
just post freely.
That's what so
attractive about Snapchat.
If you take that away and cater
fully to the influencers then
it's going to lose it's magic
and it's going to become the
Facebook and
Instagram and stuff.
- I don't think it'll ever,
I don't think they will ever
make that information public.
- Really?
It's something we care about
that nobody else cares about.
Just look what
happened with your score.
Score was something that
used to be very visible.
You didn't have to follow
someone or them to follow you
back to see their Snapchat score
which is have any Snaps you've
received and opened in
addition to how many
individual snaps
that you have sent.
And now that has something that
has been becomes more restricted
in how you can view.
That person you have to follow
them and they have to follow you
back in order to be able to
see their Snapchat score.
Given that information alone
that they're already starting to
withhold some of that, some of
those metrics I don't think they
would ever come out and make
views and screenshots something
that everyone can see.
- Are we watching Snapchat kind
of evolve mainly into just back
into a messaging platform again?
- I think it always was
a messaging platform.
That was the main goal and
certainty with this chat 2.0
upgrade which, really seamless,
it's really good update.
- It's really cool.
- I think they're solidifying
their place as a competitor to
Facebook Messenger
and What's App.
- Here's a crazy question,
do you think that we would ever
see them take away stories?
- No because it's the only
thing that makes it
a viable option for brands.
You don't see brands doing
anything effective on WeChat or
Facebook Messenger.
- Yeah.
- Those purely messaging apps
aren't a territory that brands
have a viable play in, at least
right now in anything
that I've seen.
Stories is what made
discover possible.
- Right.
- Any sort of
publishing possible.
- Obviously, we survive
off the stories but--
- Absolutely, you don't have to
send snaps to every single which
back in the day that's exactly
what we would do and learning
that you could only send to
200 people at a time and.
- mplatco goes OG by the way.
OG.
- What's OG?
- It means--
- Original gangster.
- Does mean original gangster.
Is that what it means?
- I was like what was OG?
- Yeah, okay I got it right.
- No, Nick.
- [Nick] Yes, I'm
shaking my head at you.
- Oh ok.
- Well do you have
another question?
- [India] That was
super interesting.
I just wanted to get
the discussion started.
Any final thoughts?
Usually on the show we do a
question of the day for the
community and everybody answers
it in the comments on Facebook
and YouTube.
So maybe each of you could ask
a question of the day and we'll
have three today.
- Do you follow me?
(laughter from all)
If you don't, CyreneQ.
- I have a question I have two,
maybe I'll give
you my second one. Okay.
First question, there are two
types of content on Snapchat.
There's the kind highly refined
with music and filters and very
much a storytelling
piece of content.
And then there is the day-to-day
that stuff Gary does and
what I'm wondering is how the
general public feels about that
highly refined almost outside of
the scope of what Snapchat was
intended for type of content.
Is that something that you like?
Or is the live streaming,
no second chance just take it,
post it is that more
something that you enjoy?
What kind of
content you like better?
- [India] That's
a good question.
- So that I can do it.
- What's your other question?
I can't top that question.
- Have you ever unfollowed
someone on Snapchat?
If so, why?
- I unfollowed DJ Khaled.
- [India] I unfollowed
him the other day too.
- I got bored.
- [India] I can only watch us
with his flower so many times.
- Whoa, bless up.
- I loved him but his
stories really long
and now with autoplay.
- You unfollowed him?
- [India] I did.
- And so did you?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Maybe that's what.
You need refined content,
you need everyday content.
There's not choosing both.
You need can just mix it up
or you can get unfollowed.
There's your answer
to your question.
- My question I was going to ask
Gary but we didn't have time was
what do you think will be the
first social media platform in
terms of what will entail on VR?
That's what I'm very
curious about right now.
Any day now there will be that
first platform and everybody's
going to get on day one and
that's going to be all the
future celebrities are going
to be VR celebrities and
it's like who's going to be that?
I always think like
five years down the road.
- Well I can tell you if you as
Gary that question he probably
be able to find the answer and
whether or not he is investing
in that VR platforms but I
certainly don't think that
it's anywhere near.
There might be something
that pops up but I don't think
there's anything that's going
to really have traction for
at least five years.
- I have a question.
How do you find people
to follow that are not your
friends on Snapchat?
- I go to the11thsecond.com.
- That?
- Props for Cyrene.
She's done more for the Snapchat
community of artists and
storytellers and influencers.
The11thsecond.com really was
the Discover section in Snapchat
that was nonexistent and it's
an amazing platform where you
should go and
(bell dings) look at
all fantastic Snapchatters.
- If I was you I would go to
The11thSecond.com
- Like this.
- Okay, we're done.
- Oh wait I want to show the
pictures that I drew of Gary,
hold on.
It's Gary Vaynerchuk,
does it look like him?
(all laughing)
- [Taylor] No.
- Is actually mplatco.
They look like each other.
- [India] That's amazing.
- [Mike] It only looks
exactly like him.
- [India] That's freaking crazy.
- [DRock] That's really good.
(upbeat hip hop music)